yeah let's get started all right well
welcome to the simons institute
uh and welcome to the the first workshop
of the semester the synthesis of models
and systems workshop
uh that's part of the program on
theoretical foundations of computer
systems i'm very happy to have you all
here
uh a big thank you to the organizers
radhu grossu
rasbordik rusika piskach and sanjeet
sashiya
um enjoy enjoy the workshop it's on
almost every monday through the semester
so uh i'll head over to
rushika thank you very much and uh thank
you all
for being here uh as the answer
as peter just said it will be almost
every monday
except next monday because next monday
is the president's day
and also it won't be once uh the date
which i now forgot when is actually
the richard carp lecture but uh anyway
that's almost every monday you can block
now for the rest of the semesters we
hope to see you here and that we can see
many
interesting talks and many discussions
about software synthesis
so the organizers are raz
radu and sanjit and myself and we kind
of envisioned that this
uh sam this uh synthesis seminar will go
through the following
initially we will have a couple of
tutorials and we are very excited today
to have
ben finkbeiner to start this with the
tutorial on
reactive synthesis because as you know
reactive synthesis was
that uh is something that started this
interest in the synthesis
and then uh through after tutorials we
will uh
actually have a theme of the day so for
every
day we will have a couple of talks
program is still being
created as we go so it's a online
synthesis of the program
uh and uh each in each team of the day
we will have a couple of
talks followed by the students talk so
we also
ask you if you have a student interested
in synthesis
please please please motivate them to
attend this
you know like you can register for free
they can just be attendees
and uh you know like we hope to have a
very exciting
uh uh work on the synthesis that won't
only present
what is what this happened in the
synthesis but that will also outline
exciting new ideas that we hope will
bring the research in the program
synthesis
couple of steps further after these
workshops
so uh that's about the workshop
and we kind of thank you all on the
behalf of
organizers for being there and also we
count on you to participate and when we
ask you would you be willing
to give a talk to say sure gladly now
let me go to our first
speaker that's uh my pleasure uh that's
been ping piner it is really
my great pleasure to introduce him uh
ben is actually one of the
first uh when i was still i met him when
i was a student
in sarbrook and he was he just and he
was barely
a professor himself he just finished his
phd so i'm kind of very
excited that you know like now after all
these years we meet
almost in berkeley uh and shame that
it's not
in person but it's virtual so ben finish
phd
in nearby in stanford with zohar mana
and uh ever since that he was his
research was reactive synthesis
run time verification hyper properties
fairness right now at cispa which is
inside brooklyn
and also uh when it comes to the um
there is like a recognitions you
probably have uh
heard that he received this very large
erc
award uh that's a really really big
money grant and he received the best
paper award at
uh i hope but also what is impressive is
that
the number of students that he graduated
he and he already graduate he's
so such a young professor and he's
already academic
grandfather his first professor student
already is professor and he already has
students so
when uh we couldn't find a better person
to talk about the active synthesis and
we are really excited uh that you are
agreed to give this talk thank you
and also maybe one technicalities i will
monitor
a chat so if you have any questions
please just write it and then i will
stop there and uh write
questions all i will also look if
someone is raising hand if you prefer to
raise hand thank you
all right uh thanks very much fujitsu
for this really nice
introduction um you failed to mention
that uh
you know we didn't just teach together
but also it's a lot of great
great research together right but
yeah thanks very much for the
introduction thanks very much the
organizers for having me
this is a great pleasure to talk with
you about
synthesis um i'm using
a setup that i normally use for uh for
teaching and that i have
actually not tried out before for where
i talked like this
so um you know if if you can't read
anything or anything else goes wrong
uh let me know also
um let's make this as interactive
as possible i'm not sure if i can see
the
chat really so i'll rely on rajita to uh
to read if there's something going on on
the chat but i can hear you so if you
just
jump in i think that works uh fine
um yeah so reactive synthesis is of
course
an intriguing topic it's an old topic
right it has been around for
more than uh 60 years um
and you know it has shifted in in many
ways uh
from a purely uh theoretical uh
theoretical endeavor to something that
has practical applications um and yet
there are so many uh questions uh still
open even about uh about the most uh
fundamental uh
things so um i was thinking
uh i can't really do justice today to
the full
um sort of area of course but i will
um do the following
i will start with a brief uh history
this is just uh to do justice to the
fact that there is uh
uh 60 years of work so i just want to
step
through the the highlights uh what most
people will think of when they think of
reactive synthesis
then there there's a part uh where we
talk about the basic algorithms uh
which are the uh established things you
can use uh
in order to build a reactive uh
synthesis uh
uh uh algorithm right uh just the basics
not that too much depth and then
i'll have a third part uh which i called
challenges and
these are really just three areas that i
think are extremely promising
and where there is already uh uh quite
some research of course but that
are definitely far from uh being
resolved so i think these might be
three topics that could be fun um
to discuss uh also during the the
simon's
institute um so i'm guessing uh
you know i'll have some ideas of course
to share on
on these three areas but uh this is not
uh
um you know final in in any uh
way all right so let's uh get into it
uh and a brief history of uh
reactive synthesis and there can't be a
talk about reactive uh
synthesis without alonso church so
let's go to the hands of church and
church's problem which
was initiated in the 1950s
but it is um unchanged until today and
uh is sort of synonymous with the
reactive
synthesis problem so suppose you have
a specification that talks about
sequences of valuations of input and
output variables
so these are infinite sequences so we're
talking about a reactive system
and it gets in an infinite sequence of
inputs and outputs an infinite
sequence of outputs and there is a
specification that relates the two
for example a s1 s formula or any other
sequential
logic now our task is
to construct an implementation that is a
finite state machine
represented for example as a circuit
that translates the inputs into outputs
such that the given specification is
correct
okay a classic example here would be
an arbiter right so you have uh
requests from two clients r1 and r2
and you're supposed to produce grants g1
and
g2 and the typical requirements are
that you want mutual exclusion so there
are never two grands g1 and g2 at the
same time
and at the same time you have
responsiveness
so every request ri is eventually
followed
by a grand gi
okay so obviously this is a
specification that can be
implemented and you might do so with a
finite state machine that say
starts in in this state and as long as
there is no
request it just stays there if a request
r1
comes in then it goes to a new state
where it actually outputs the first
grant grant
g1 right and as long as new requests
only for
the first client come in it stays there
and keeps
outputting the first grant likewise if
we're in the initial state and the
request for the second client comes in
then we just start outputting grants for
the second client
and now if um the two requests come in
at the same time
then things get more interesting um so
you might for example go back and forth
between giving out the first grant and
the second grant
and back and forth until you're done
satisfying all requests so
when you read the human this
specification then you might immediately
think of an uh of a finite state machine
like this
which is a correct implementation of
the given specification now of course
when you do sentences
one of the basic facts of life is that
you get what you specified
not necessarily more or less so
there is a totally acceptable
alternative solution
which you see here which only has two
states and
simply goes back and forth between
giving out the first grand and the
second grant
completely ignoring uh what requests
come in why is this a legitimate
solution
well it does satisfy mutual exclusion
and
response right if there were to come a
request it would eventually be
answered by a grant the fact
that we also have in mind the
requirement that
you only give out grants if there was
actually a request that justifies that
is not specified in the uh specification
and therefore you have no guarantee that
the the implementation generated by the
synthesis will have such extra
properties okay now
george's problem was solved pretty
quickly
um so the original solution due to
buchi and lander translated the
synthesis problem
into a game so we have a player zero
that's responsible for the outputs and
the player one
that's responsible for the inputs and
we're just looking at the sequence of
inputs and outputs that are generated
by letting those two players pick
outputs and inputs
in turn now
our player zero wins the game if the
sequence of inputs
and outputs satisfies the specification
otherwise otherwise player 1 wins the
game
so really we're interested in a winning
strategy
for player 0. if such a strategy exists
then that defines a valid implementation
and dually if player one wins then
there does not exist a winning i mean
there does not exist an implementation
for our uh specification
another early solution is
automata so
you can view the same problem in
automata
theoretic terms by looking
at uh such winning strategies such
winning strategies are trees
so uh you look at it from the
perspective of player zero
uh player zero needs to pick the outputs
in response to the input so
this is an infinite tree that branches
according to the possible inputs
so in in this example here it's uh
there's only one bit
that is either set or not so the empty
set means
zero the set containing i means the
variable i
is set to one so we're looking at the
infinite
tree that branches according to these
inputs
and in each node of the tree we see the
value of the strategy
that is what player zero is going to
output in response to the inputs seen so
far
so the existence of such a strategy
is corresponds to player zero winning
the game and we can build a triathlon
that
accepts all the winning strategies so
this means that if we check the
emptiness of that uh triotomaten that is
equivalent
to determining who wins the the
synthesis
game there there is in fact a one-to-one
correspondence in the sense that
uh checking emptiness of triatomater can
be
again seen as a game namely the
emptiness gain
and uh so we can translate to three
automata and
uh back again the relevance for for
synthesis is that
now we have a mechanism to represent all
the solutions
and that of course is useful if we have
additional requirements on
the solutions we can transform this
representation which gives us more
flexibility
as in the game representation
okay now this uh early
work was um based on logics like
like s1s which are of course
let's say impractical in the sense that
there is no
um elementary translation to automata
but this changed with uh ltl
so in the 80s with logics like
ltl that were useful in
verification the corresponding
synthesis problem got let's say a lot
more interesting
because it's much more more feasible
to translate the logic into automata
so this is a work by amir neeli
of course also by
amir and roni rosner came another
very interesting generalization of the
problem
which is the the synthesis of
distributed
systems so in church's problem you
look at one circuit that is supposed to
satisfy
the specification in the distributed
version of the problem
you additionally provide a target
architecture
for your system so you have more than
one
process and you have an architecture
that regulates how these
processes can communicate with each
other
and now the synthesis problem is no
longer to just find this one
circuit but rather find a solution for
each of the processes in the
architecture
such that when you combine them again
you have a solution that satisfies
the given specification
now looking at this variation
of the problem makes it a lot harder and
the reason that synthesizing distributed
systems is so much more difficult
than synthesizing circuits is that
you're working with partial observation
let's say you have
a simple architecture with
two processes process one and
process two process one region an input
from the environment
let's call that x and then it produces y
which
is then the input that goes into process
2
who then in turn produces a variable
z now what this architecture means is
that
process 2 does not directly know about x
it only knows about x in as much as it
can deduce
from seeing y
and this means that the decisions
process 2 makes
must not depend on x directly it may
only
depend on what's visible of that in y
so if we again look at the strategy tree
of the overall system then that of
course branches according
to the inputs of the system so on
according to the values of x
and then in each node it would give us
the values of all
the the variables including y and z
and you might have a situation where
two nodes have different values of set
like zero here
and uh one there
but the history that takes you to those
two nodes
has the same values of y right so in
in the first step we saw y is one and
then here we see y is zero
here and also there so
our process too can't really distinguish
whether it is in this node or in that
node
right only process one knows whether we
are here or
there because there are difference
visible in the x but since there is no
difference visible in the y it's not
legal to have different values of set
in those two uh nodes
so the only consistent or i mean the
consistent strategy would have z
equals one here and there or set equals
zero in both cases but in any case it
needs to have the same
value so this additional consistency
requirement makes the problem
very hard and in fact
there's a long history of
results that show that the distributed
synthesis problem is
decidable for specific architectures
the original one from william rosner was
the pipeline
so you have an environment that produces
some information that goes into the
first process
and then that gets handed over to the
second process
but the important point is that the
second process does not have
new information it only gets a subset of
the information that the first
process got and so forth so if the
if the architecture is hierarchical in
this sense then
the synthesis problem is decidable
there is a result by kuperman embardi
that generalized this
blue rings so you can have ring
architectures
that also have this property that the
information is entered at one
particular process in the ring
then we did a small uh generalization of
this
to weekly ordered architectures which
means that
as long there is a weak order that ranks
the processes in terms of their
informedness the the problem
uh stays decidable and for the
synchronous
uh systems this is already the
borderline everything beyond that
becomes undecidable
so the in the original work by uh
uh rosanna and lady that there was
already this architecture that has
two independent uh processes and
uh that that is the the master
architecture that has an
undecidable synthesis problem
there has been quite some work on
asynchronous
systems so systems where you don't have
a common clock
meaning that the the state changes
happen in
lockstep but rather there is
independent computation going on and
in that area there are also a number of
interesting
decidability results in particular
there's the one
by uh mushor and valukevich which tells
us that
synthesizing systems that have an
acyclic communication architecture
so for example two processes
that talk to each other or a star
architecture
where you have a process in the middle
that talks to many other processes
these are all examples for distributed
systems
that are decidable in the
setting of asynchronous systems
so unlike for synchronous systems there
is no
no clear boundary yet where the
decidability
lies we only have these examples or
decidable architectures
okay so the um the bottom line
of this story about distributed
systems is that
there is a large class of architectures
for which
synthesis is decidable in principle
because you can build it re-automate
them that
represents all solutions and then you
you just need to check that
pre-automaton for emptiness
however typically that three automaton
is
huge so for an architecture with n
components
you need n plus one exponentially many
states so a tower
of uh of uh n plus one exponent
so the complexity is uh
non-elementary and of course in general
uh the the problem is uh undecidable
so this means that uh you know
at this point of the discussion there's
quite some doubt if this
leads anywhere right because uh we have
a problem that's in general undecidable
but where it is decidable it has this
horrendous uh
complexity so you might question
whether this is really uh
solvable in in practice
and uh at this point in the story i
think uh
there is one event that uh gave people a
lot of uh
hope um and that was the the synthesis
of the umber
uh bus protocol in uh 2007
um ah high near i didn't notice you
there until now uh so yes uh
by near and uh and quite a few others um
so i think what is so encouraging about
this is that it was
the first time a real system got
synthesized i mean at least something
that is being used in uh
in industry you probably have some
version of this
protocol on your cell phone
so clearly synthesis uh
is not just a toy right it can do
something uh useful
now the umba bus protocol is a high
performance on-chip
you have something like 16 masters and
clients that communicate to each other
across the bus and
the the bus got specified using
i think in the original work 12
guarantees
so these are temporal requirements of
the form that a new access
does not start until the current master
releases the bus
and the the bus arbiter only needed to
satisfy these uh
guarantees under certain assumptions
um on the behavior of the clients so for
example that the
clients indicate infinitely often that
they have
finished processing the data and are
releasing the bus again
so the reason why it suddenly
became possible to synthesize
something realistic like this was
at least to a large extent the
discovery of of gr1
so the the general reactivity of one
fragment of ltl consists of
specifications of this form so you have
a conjunction
of assumptions and the conjunction of
guarantees and it is restricted
what you can express in these
assumptions and guarantees
so you can state what needs to happen
initially with initialization properties
which are just
state formulas then you have safety
properties
that describe the rules of the game
right so they are of the form if some
condition holds then
something else needs to hold in the next
step
and lastly you have liveness properties
of this form
something needs to happen infinitely
often
and now you're restricted that you have
assumptions of this form
and guarantees of this form and you're
looking at an implication
between such a conjunction of
assumptions and
guarantees now the great thing here is
that
this can actually be checked in
exponential
time uh near would probably say
in polynomial time because
if you like uh you you can measure the
the complexity of course in the
in the size of the state graph which is
again exponential in
uh in the size of uh of the formula
but but even if you say this is uh
then i think it's a it's a great uh
result because
i mean after all we're coming from
non-elementary
or in in the case of full ltl at least
doubly exponential
down uh to uh to an exponential time
algorithm and this it turned out
in a way that it was still a useful uh
specification
so um i think
this is the reason why synthesis
suddenly got adopted
also in in robotics and and many
areas that uh are not traditionally
connected
let's say to uh to formal methods or or
theory right
because there was an uh algorithm with
which you could actually
do things okay
another development that in my opinion
changed
the game was bounded synthesis
so in general in synthesis we ask the
question
if there is i mean is there an
implementation that satisfies the
specification
and by implementation we need we mean a
finite state
representation now in bounded synthesis
you ask
is there an implementation with no more
than n states
which in a way is a small difference
because you're looking for a finite
implementation in the first place but
the difference of course is that now you
have this parameter
and that gives you a maximum
that a maximum size that you need
to look at now
the immediate implication of this
change of perspective is that everything
becomes decidable
because you have an upper bound which
you need to uh
search and of course now you can you
have a
measure on the output rather than on the
input
and it turns out that this measure on
the output is much more favorable
because uh you can solve pretty much any
uh synthesis problem in np
in np in this bound right not in the
specification but this means that
the uh one process architectures in in
church's original problem
or i mean which have uh doubly
exponential complexity in
in the ltl specification or the pipeline
architectures which have
non-elementary complexity in the
specification
and even pleni and rosner's
independent processes which are
undecidable
they all drop to np
now np is of course not the most
scalable
complexity you might wish for
but it still means that no matter
what specification and architecture
you're coming from
as long as your solution is reasonably
small
you have a way of finding it
so this i think changes
uh the picture from something that looks
impossible
to something that looks a bit tricky in
terms of scalability but
but definitely solvable
okay what else happened so i i think a
lot of
improvements in uh reasoning method uh
happened
so there's of course the the big ticket
uh result
um that parity games
for which we we have a whole range of
algorithms
that run in exponential time they got
solved in quasi-polynomial time
we now have something like four very
similar algorithms
that uh solve peritones in uh
in quasi-polynomial time and of course
parity
solving parity games is sort of the
the key uh problem in uh synthesis
now it turned out that these
algorithms at least so far aren't that
useful in
uh in uh practice they tend to be among
the the slowest
algorithms we have at least in practice
so the impact of this was was not
that earth-shattering as you might have
hoped for
what was much more of an impact
was actually simply uh better
engineering
so in the last years a new uh
crop of tools and uh
and also algorithms uh came around that
uh
that just worked much much better so i
uh i
mentioned here uh a slick's a tool
developed in uh
in munich which uh you know
performs amazingly well uh even though i
wouldn't say
that it you know it's it's not
comparable in its uh
in its uh theoretical shift uh to the
new parity game
algorithms but it's just very very
clever
in in many aspects for example it treats
subformula separately uh uh
exploits uh um similarities between
sub-formulas and uh
and many ideas of this nature
but uh better engineering really uh
uh changed uh things a lot
and uh then there was a lot of progress
in
constraint solving techniques that uh
are helpful in uh
in synthesis in particular um
i mean the sort of set solving had
improved earlier right but
uh qbf and and dqbf uh solving really
got better in the last uh
a few years let's say dqbf solving in
the last five years
and that that also helped enormously
i'm pointing here to the under 10 troops
thesis because that's a recent
thesis on the topic if you just want to
track
these developments
okay so so where are we uh now
um two years ago we
looked at again a
rather elaborate case uh study
so this is a it's the the sundroids uh
game it's an arcade game it's a handheld
device that has an led screen and it has
an fpga on the back
and all kinds of sensors acceleration
sensors and so forth
and what you can do with this is play a
game where you're
flying on a spaceship and there are all
sorts of enemies coming at you from all
directions
and then you can look at the situation
in multiple views
you have like a radar screen and then
you can look through the window
and all this is displayed to you on this
led
display so it is run
very very efficiently on an fpga and the
code for this fpga
consists of 24 different
modules that interact with a base system
with another
say 40 functions so this is a
pretty elaborate uh type of uh
implementation
that needs to keep track of a lot of uh
data for example
the positions of the different uh
aircraft
and and so forth and
this was actually not hard to synthesize
using the the latest
synthesis algorithm of course also
concepts like
compositionality and uh and program uh
synthesis
that uh i'll i'll talk about uh in the
third part uh
today but to me that suggests
that we have reached a point where you
can actually develop systems
with synthesis so this is a very nicely
developed system
if you look at the specification that's
much nicer
compared to a manually written code
it's certainly something that you can
also develop manually it's not
that the synthesis can do something that
you couldn't do as a
as a human programmer but
of course you have to guarantee that all
your properties
are actually uh true on this uh
on the system and it has quite a few
uh aspects that uh human programmers
would consider tricky
for example the the correct timing of uh
the signals that
that that go onto the the screen you
know as the
as the different leds uh on the screen
um
are activated
all right so this is my
short uh history
i will now uh start
going through some um some of the basic
uh algorithms uh
that are in play here
okay so the basic story
for synthesizing systems from ltl
formulas
goes like this you start with the
formula then translate it into
a automaton
let's say an undetermined security
automaton then you determinize this
automaton you get a deterministic
automaton say a deterministic parity
automaton
then you separate out the choice of the
inputs
and the outputs that is you turn this
automaton into a game this is a parity
game
and now you just see whether player zero
wins the game if so
the winning strategy for player zero is
your
solution let's say
our specification is a simple response
property so globally whenever there's a
request
i want to see eventually a grant then
you might translate this into a
deterministic
parity automaton so the disparity
automaton has two states
one where you say everything is good
nothing is to do
so you stay in the state if either
nothing happens or
you give out a grant or there's a
request and immediately also
a grant then you just stay here when
there's a request you go into the second
state where you're waiting for a grant
so you stay here
while nothing happens or further
requests happen but no no grant
and when the grant happens then you go
back to this initial state
so this is labeled with parity colors uh
two and one
so the automaton accepts if the highest
uh color
occurring intimately often is even so
essentially if uh
if you come back to the initial state
infinitely often
okay so we take this automaton and
translate it into a game so
we have our two players right so
we we uh start here in uh
in the initial state of the automaton
and then um we can
decide whether
we do nothing or give out a grant
either way we stay in state
p and now the um
the environment can either also do
nothing that is
sent no request in which case we go back
to the upper state
or it can send out a
request so if our implementation
chose not to put out a grant then we go
into queue
and wait for this to happen
and now here from q our implementation
has
two options it can either do nothing
that is not give out a grant in which
case we we go to this state uh up here
right
so we stay in in queue in the automaton
and
uh just output nothing so we go back and
forth
until we actually give out a grant or
it can choose to give out a grant in
which case
we go back to the original state to p
so we have taken the automaton and
turned it into a game that just
alternates between the two players and
mimics
what happens in the automaton based on
the choices
of the two players
now there is a winning strategy for our
implementation it can for example
do nothing initially which
takes it here now the environment might
respond by also
not producing a request in which case we
simply go back
or by producing a request in which case
we go down here
and now our winning strategy might
actually choose to answer this request
with a grant
in which case we come back to the
original state
so we have one winning strategy for
for this uh game and we can turn this
winning strategy into an implementation
that then just does what uh our
strategy suggests namely um while there
is no request
just do nothing but if there's a request
go here and issue a grant
and then go back to
the original state
okay now a quick question why why do we
use
deterministic parity automata here the
first question is why
why do we need the deterministic
automata
well the problem if you were to use
non-deterministic automata is that
you might get rejecting runs of the
automaton even
if you run the automaton on an accepted
sequence right because there is another
run of the non-deterministic automaton
that
accepts the sequence and that might
penalize our player zero
because it might be the case that player
zero loses a play
just because we end up in the wrong run
of the non-deterministic automaton
not because the player did something
wrong
so for example if you have a disjunction
and uh one says uh eventually we have
globally
that uh the input uh is true and
uh and uh the the uh
in the next step the output is true or
we have infinitely often that the
input is false and in the next step the
output is false
then player 0 has a winning strategy
namely simply to repeat
what uh the input at the output
but if we would ask our player to pick
one of the disjuncts
then it would not know which one to pick
because it depends on the behavior of
of the environment so since we don't
want
to burden one of our two players with
making this uh choosing the disjunct uh
on which to win we simply eliminate the
disjunction in the automaton and
look at the deterministic automaton
okay and the other question of course
why not deterministic buchi automata
well because if we start with ltl then
uh
deterministic buchi automata would not
be strong enough to express
all ldl properties so we just go to
deterministic parity
automata okay
now the complexity of this going from
ltl to a non-deterministic
visual automaton is exponential
going from the non-deterministic bishop
automaton to the deterministic parity
automaton
is again exponential so
your number of states becomes doubly
exponential
and you need an exponential number of
colors in the
parity automaton as a result
now going from the deterministic parity
automaton to the parity game
is just a syntactic transformation where
we separate
the two players so that doesn't affect
the size but then we need to resolve
the i mean we need to solve the
resulting parity game
which is polynomial in the number of
states
and either if if you take the
one of the classic algorithms
exponential in the number of colors
or even less so but in any case
uh because the number of states is
already doubly exponential
you end up with a doubly exponential
cost
interestingly independently of the
precise complexity of the
parity game algorithm because it's the
the complexity really is uh dominated by
the number of uh
states so that may be one one reason why
the new parity game algorithms uh don't
help this much
because uh the the complexity really
lies in the number of states
rather than uh the colors
okay now what people are usually usually
really worried
about in this uh construction is
actually
not so much the uh the two exponents
but uh this particular step
uh going from uh non-deterministic wiki
automata to uh deterministic
uh parity automata
the um uh well the standard way to go
from here to there is
via suffraz construction which is
infamous because it's not only expensive
but also really difficult uh to
implement for example in a symbolic
algorithm so because of that there are
a number of suffra less constructions
so the first uh obvious way is to just
bypass
the non-deterministic automata so you
use a construction that takes you
from the ldl formula directly to the
deterministic
parity automaton this is for example
done
in in slicks so uh there's a
direct construction that is very clever
in
in the use of the sub formulas of ltl
and furthermore uh completely bypasses
uh this
need for the for phosphorus construction
another option is to go directly
from the ltl formula not to a parity
automaton
but rather to a safety automaton
safety automata are much easier to
handle in particular symbolically than
than parity automata but of course you
can't
recognize the same language as an ltl
formula with a
safety automaton but what you can do is
you can approximate
the language with the safety automaton
so there is a construction that gives
you a family
of safety automata that has
the guarantee that eventually you will
have a safety automaton
that includes your solution assuming
that
your there is a solution for the
original ltl
formula so you can think of that as if
you have eventually p
then you just start with an automaton
that waits one step
then two steps then three steps and four
steps if there is a finite
solution that will accomplish p and n
steps then
the nth automaton will catch that
solution okay so
by going through this sequence of more
and more precise
safety automata all you have to do in
each iteration
is uh solve a safety gain
all right uh bern can i ask no question
oh yes please um so the
the old the three are some of the base
mention of representing all possible
solutions to
stop some some subset of games that you
mentioned much earlier in your history
that one has an advantage in a sense
that if i have access to all possible
solutions i can try to
do extra things with them if i'm
interested in a particular solution i
can try to pick it out of the bunch etc
so these three methods that you just
that you just
highlighted can you say something in
general about
their advantages and disadvantages in
terms of
if i had an interest in enumerating
solutions
what would they look like i don't know
if my question is
good enough okay you're
uh a number of steps ahead in the story
uh but but it's an
uh an outstanding question of course i
mean the
um i guess you're asking we don't want
just any solution usually we want a good
solution
and if i have a tree automaton then i
can delay the problem until i check the
emptiness of the tree automaton to pick
the one solution that i want
here in these approaches you may have to
do this much
earlier so in particular in this
construction what you do is
you look at the sub formulas and you
you solve the games represented by these
subformulas individually and then you
try to combine these solutions into a
big
solution so um you do that for
efficiency because
uh you know you may not even be able to
construct the
the full automaton in one go but you can
already build automata for the sub
formula so you get started with what you
uh what you have but of course it's
impossible at this stage
to do a global optimization you do a
local optimization
and then you do strategy iteration to
adapt until you have a solution
that that works globally so indeed it's
much
more difficult uh to to add extra
uh things like minimality or so
into uh the consideration however these
tools
don't do so badly on the on the quality
and
the reason is that this compositional
approach
gives you a reasonably small solution it
often actually does better than
the global solution which does a full
product construction where you lose
sight of things
here you have a much more manageable
state space
to optimize on and then of course they
do a post
optimization and again try to optimize
the solution
they have afterwards
now the the approach
that approximates things with the
safety uh automaton
actually goes into the direction of
minimality
because in my example with eventually p
if you bound the number of steps until
you hit the p that
that sort of forces you into a more
efficient solution right you don't allow
to take 25 steps if there's also a
solution that only takes five steps
so that already goes in in the solution
but it
also does not have a guarantee that for
example your state space is uh
is minimal it it just has this um
optimization of the reactivity uh
behavior
so all in all i think none of these
solutions
are targeted towards producing um
optimal solutions bounded synthesis is
way much better than that because there
you optimize a global bound
but it turns out that uh they do
surprisingly well
uh in in practice um
because i think that this is how a human
would uh would approach the thing and
that gives you a reasonably uh good
solution whereas uh having a full
product is uh is just scary
all right
yeah uh uh near this is again for you
so uh the um the gr1
specifications show their advantage uh
here
so uh you remember we we had this
restriction uh through
the specifications where you have a
conjunction of assumptions and a
conjunction of
guarantees and they are restricted to
safety properties of this form
and these liveness properties of that
form so infinitely often
something happens now the safety
properties
of this form lead
actually to the exponential state space
because you need to keep track
of the the activated formulas the
the formulas where the fee has become
true and you now need to make good on
the promise
of uh c but the real magic happens
on the liveness properties um
because of their special form you get a
parity game
with just three colors
and this i will show you on the next
slide
so if you have a formula of this
form where you say infinitely often a1
and the internet of
a2 and so forth is my assumption and
then i have infinitely often g1
and infinitely often g2 and so forth are
my guarantees
then i can implement this in a game that
has
an outer loop and an inner loop
so so this is an inner loop and the
other loop steps through the guarantees
so it waits for the first guarantee to
become true then we go to the second
guarantee
and so forth until we have stepped
through all the guarantees
and then we go back a full circle
so if the if we go infinitely often
through the full circle then we make
good on all
guarantees therefore the game is won
by player zero in that case now the
inner loops
just step through the assumptions so we
wait for assumption a1
then assumption a2 and so forth until we
hit the
assumption am and then we go back
and it might not happen that we step
through the assumptions infinitely often
before we make progress on the
guarantees
so if this happens then we see an odd
color
infinitely often right so player one
went
and now lastly uh there are these mini
loops where we just wait for the next
assumption
uh to become true and uh well
if that if we get stuck in one of those
loops
then we have color zero and uh it's
player zero
who went right so we have the three
colors
the player color zero to wait for the
next assumption
uh color one to wait for the next
guarantee and color two
if we complete the full circle and this
is all we need
uh to resolve uh the gr1
uh synthesis problem so we have an
exponential
gain graph but we only have uh three
colors so this indeed can be
solved very efficiently
okay the
the trick in many cases is to do to
solve these
games not uh not explicitly but rather
symbolically
although it's it's not quite clear uh
whether symbolic approaches really
outperform
uh explicit state approaches
the idea of doing the symbolically is
very simple so you have a symbolic
transition relation and then you define
a controllable predecessor
which here from the perspective of
player one says that
there is an um sorry um
yeah there is an input by player one
such that for all inputs
by player zero um i have a
successor state in my my given uh
set right so this lets me back propagate
by one step what uh player one uh can
enforce in the game and if you build a
fixed point uh based on this
controllable predecessor
then you get all the states where player
1 wins the game
and this is exactly the unsafe region of
the game
from the perspective of of player 0.
okay you can implement this construction
for example with
bdds but as i said it's not completely
clear
uh whether symbolic approaches are
really superior to explicit
state approaches here so definitely part
of the success story of gr1 was that it
had a bdd based uh
implementation if you look at
the recent centcom results
then indeed there are still
bdd-based solvers that
do well but sticks which
starts winning more and more categories
is an explicit state
approach so clearly
uh edds aig's uh
and also sat and increasingly qbf
seem to do well on on circuits with
large input vectors but if
you have a specification that can be
decomposed well and uh you can
solve the sub i mean reasonably small uh
sub games uh efficiently
then it seems that um
explicit state algorithms are really the
the way to go here
okay so
i want uh to get started with um
with bounded synthesis but uh
uh when would be a good time uh to take
a break uh
um is that now a good time or should we
go on for a little bit further
i see some nodding so let's then take a
five-minute coffee break
before because are there any last-minute
questions for ben before he goes to
bounded synthesis
okay so let's then take it a break
lately all right so i guess five minutes
uh yes let's start at whatever time in
time zone you are guys at 35.
that's good everybody
so you've got a lot of the snow because
it's alright
you should see a picture quite a lot of
snow
how are things in canada cold but no
snow
for us it called will start in a couple
reverse first we had the real
real cold like uh almost like well i
know
it's not canadian real cold but real
field was minus 24
celsius so almost
yeah and then we got snow and now we're
getting getting snow again
yeah then before we start since you're
here
i actually got several questions about
your slides and techniques that you're
using
you have to before you're allowed to
continue with the talk you need to tell
us what you're using and
because i got even okay i won't tell
from whom but the
question was like uh it really makes me
much more
involved actually maybe because it feels
more like a real talk so there were
really
couple of people saying that this is
great so maybe you can tell us
what this technique that you're using
because we all want to use that now
it's absolutely impressive man i i
you made our day you know people might
think that time was institute that had
this
incredible technology you know but you
should you should tell
yeah all right
yeah i'm very glad you say that because
i was a little bit worried that it's uh
not
not quite as sharp as uh as usual uh
screen sharing so zoom optimizes
somewhat differently
if you have a video rather than a static
image
like a slide but other than that
this is a tool called obs that lets you
combine different video sources so uh
in this case my my keynote slides
together with the
image from the camera
and uh essentially this is a green
screen
effect i mean normally green means you
stand in front of a green screen and
then that's replaced uh with uh with an
image
here uh my slide i mean the color white
in my
slides is made transparent so i can
stand
behind the behind the slides
so i also think this is much nicer in
teaching because you
i mean you don't have to choose whether
you look at the slides or at the person
you can look at it at the same time
so i i recommend it uh for that
okay but now back to uh more importantly
obviously
how did you download it so don't go that
fast
so what do you download it's obs so
where is it
obs is an uh open source uh tool
you can uh um there you go
thanks ana
okay and now to the slide
okay um yes so bonded synthesis
solves of course in principle the same
problem we have an ltl
specification and we want to find an
implementation
so what we do is we translate the
ltl formula into an automaton this time
into a universal
kobuchi automaton um i'll explain that
in a in a moment
you don't actually have to go down to a
deterministic automaton
um it suffices uh to uh
build a universal automaton which is
actually exponentially cheaper than
going to the deterministic automaton and
then
you build a constraint system such that
any solution
to the constraint system is a solution
for your original
ltl formula now
if you can do this translation from here
to there
without losing um anything but then you
get
a constrained system over the natural
numbers
that is not in general decidable
so what you do is you introduce a bound
so your constraint system actually
refers
to a bounded domain and then you can
solve the constraint system up to that
bound
in np
quickly how does this work with uh
universal uh kobichi automata
they're the the dual of
non-deterministic bj automata
so uh you you can for example generate
them
by uh building the the non-deterministic
automaton for the negated formula and
then
pretending the non-deterministic
automaton you get is actually a
universal automaton
so it accepts a sequence if all
runs of the automaton satisfy the corpus
condition so in
in this example uh where we want to just
check if
our arbiter works correctly so it does
not have two grants at the same time and
every request is eventually
answered by our grant uh we would have
these three states
the uh the green state which
uh we start out in and uh that
uh would stay active uh throughout the
the sequence
um it would uh fail to accept if two
grants came in at the
at the same time but if there is uh just
a request
request one or request two then it just
launches
into one of the successor states so
let's say if there's r1
then we stay active in green and then
additionally
we we go into the the blue state if we
also have request two
then on top of that we also go into the
red state
and there we have rejecting states so we
are only allowed to stay there
uh finitely long so we stay there let's
say in the blue state
as long as it takes until we see grand
one
so if after a finite number of steps we
see
grant one then we eventually are done
here
so we satisfy the acceptance condition
likewise here
we wait for grant two we stay here until
grant two happens if that happens after
a finite number of steps then we're done
but if we wait here forever then that
would violate
the kobushi condition
okay now an implementation is correct if
every
execution satisfies the ltl formula and
this is the case if and only if the
product of the implementation and this
automaton
has the property that on all paths the
kobuhi
condition is satisfied so let's say
we have this rather simplistic
implementation where we just go back and
forth between giving out
the first grand and the second grand and
completely ignoring
the input this is a correct
implementation of our
ltl formula so in order to check that
this is the case
we look at the product between the
solution and the universal kobushi
automaton this is this graph and now we
just make sure
that in this product we don't actually
stay in a rejecting state infinitely
long
and as you can see this is not the case
because i mean there is this
loop here that loops between the two
copies of the green
state right because we go back and forth
between one and two here
and we have a self loop on the green
state but this is fine because the green
state
is not a rejecting state if we see a
request
and go into one of the blue states
say then it only takes one
step until we get stuck simply because
in our implementation it takes at most
two steps until we see the respective
grant
so it does not take more than two
consecutive steps inside the blue
or symmetrically inside the red state
until this threat in our product
reaches an end so
this product graph is an actual proof
that
this implementation is uh
correct with respect to our
specification i.e
it is accepted by the automaton
now what we look for are annotated
implementations
that carry the argument why
the the product will not have infinitely
many visits to rejecting states in them
and for that purpose we just look in the
product
and annotate each state in the product
with the number of visits
that uh that a path to the state has
seen
on on of rejecting states
so for example here the number is zero
we have never been in a in a rejecting
state
likewise in the second green
state i mean we have gotten back and
forth as long as we want it between
those two states but the total number of
visits to rejecting states is
zero now here
the number is one because we come from
zero and
now we visit a rejecting state the blue
one so the number is one
and down here it's two but there's no
successor so it never gets higher than
two
and likewise over here uh down here the
number is one
because we come from the green state and
are now for once in the
rejecting state so this is the first
visit
and up here the number is two but it
never gets higher
than two so we put this annotation
directly on the implementation so we
indicate
for each partner in the product in this
case the blue
the green and the red state what is the
number
that you would put on the state in the
product
that limits the number of visits you
have seen on any path
that that leads to this node in the in
the product
so by having this annotation
we can of course quickly verify that
this
this annotation is correct we just check
okay coming from a blue state is there a
way
uh to go to another blue state say
and and further increasing uh the
counter no there is not because here i
am already in a state where the grand
one is
given and i can't stay in a blue state
because i can only stay there if the
if the grand one is is false so
by searching for an implementation
together
with the annotation that proves that
it's a correct
implementation we solve the synthesis
problem
so this is exactly what happens in the
constraint system so we have a
representation of the solution
that is of the finite state machine that
just
specifies how the implementation behaves
so we use a finite subset of the natural
numbers to encode the states
then have a labeling that that is a
function that maps this
set of states to boolean values
representing the the value of a
particular
output variable and then we have
transitions
so for each possible input we have a
transition i mean we have a function
that maps states to states indicating
what would be the successor state
if that particular input were to happen
and then the annotation is represented
again by functions so we have a boolean
function
that indicates uh for each state of the
implementation and each state q
of the automaton if they do happen in
combination
and then we have a rejecting bound that
well simply indicates this bound in in
the annotation
and then we add a lot of constraints
that just state that this particular
annotation
is correct so you would start by saying
okay
the state 0 the initial state
must be labeled with the green state
right because
our automaton starts in the green state
so the initial state of the
implementation must carry the green
state
and if you are in a green state then no
matter
what input comes you're going to stay in
the green state
so that means applying the transition
function once
will lead you to a state where the green
state is again
present this is simply because in our
automaton there is a self loop on the
green state we can't escape
the green state likewise
if uh with the green state and a request
comes in
then the successor must be labeled with
uh blue
right because the the automaton says if
you're in green and you see
request one then you must be in blue so
these types of constraints enforce that
the labeling is correct
with respect to the transitions of the
automaton
and then we also have uh constraints
that
make sure that the numbers are correct
so if you are in a green state that is
in a
not rejecting state then the
successor can't be labeled with a
smaller number
than the present state this just means
that whatever visits to rejecting states
you had
previously it cannot become lower on
successor states so it must be greater
or equal
but if you are in a rejecting state such
as a
blue state then you have one more visit
to a rejecting state so that number must
go up
so therefore in in those situations you
have
a strictly greater than uh condition
and so forth so with these constraints
we ensure
that the annotation is indeed correct so
if
we have a solution to our constraint
system then
that is a transition system that would
be accepted by the automaton
and therefore would necessarily satisfy
the ltl formula
now i've shown you this constraint
system here
using uninterpreted functions so
you could absolutely give this to an smt
solver
and ask the smt solver to generate
the solution what we typically
do is code it down further
to set qbf or
dqbf um so the reason obviously being
that
uh these low-level solvers are typically
more efficient and they also give us a
choice
in how symbolic the solution is going to
be
computed so essentially if you go down
to sat
then everything becomes explicit you
have an explicit table
for all these different functions and
you have a boolean value that
indicates whether or not a certain say a
certain transition is
possible if you use qbf
then you can make use of for all exists
constructions
that allow you to rather than
enumerate the values of a function just
state the existence of a function
namely for all arguments x that there is
f of x namely there is a y right
but it only allows you to do that um in
a limited way because you cannot
use the same function twice you can only
use this
encoding if if you have functions that
appear in the constraints only once
so in in the synthesis this corresponds
to a symbolic
treatment of inputs you can say that for
all
inputs there must be a successor in the
transition system
but you don't have to enumerate the
solutions you can quantify over them
and so it continues so with
dqbf you can actually
describe all the functions in the
constrained
system by by quantifiers
and this means that at least in the
representation of the constraint system
you you never have to explicitly
enumerate
the states neither of the implementation
nor of the the specification
automaton so this is the most concise
uh representation uh of the problem it's
it's much much smaller than
the the set encoding but of course the
dqbf
is a more difficult um constraint
solving problem
so it used to be that qbf
was the most effective way to solve
this type of problem but in the last two
three years
uh dqbf has actually been uh catching up
and and this is uh this is very nice
because this is the most elegant uh
formulation of uh of the constraints
that
leaves uh the most uh liberties
sort of to the to the solver so it's
it's very nice that there are now
dqbf solvers that seem to be able to
uh to exploit that
okay so
bounded synthesis is actually a decision
procedure
um i mean i'm not sure if that was uh
obvious
because uh the the way i explained the
story was of course that
you you look for a solution that is an
implementation
and you incrementally increase the bound
that you set on the size of that
solution
so in that sense it's just a model
generation right you
you increase and increase and
potentially you will never find a
an implementation because none exists
but the nice property of the
synthesis games is that they're
determined
so if player zero does not have a
winning strategy then
player one has a winning strategy so
rather than just looking at the game
from player zero's perspective i can
simultaneously look at the
game from player 1's perspective so if
the search for a solution for player 0
does not terminate
then the search for a solution of player
1
is guaranteed to terminate so this is
actually how it works
you look at the problem from both
perspectives
simultaneously and then you have a
guarantee
that eventually you will either find an
implementation
or a counter strategy or the environment
that that makes it impossible for
the system to satisfy the specification
now how long it may take to
find either one is exactly the
complexity you have
from the direct game based approach
namely you know that if you construct a
full game
this is doubly exponential in the
formula and then there exists a
positional winning strategy
on this doubly exponentially large uh
game graph
so if you if your bound
hits a doubly exponential value in the
size of the specification then you're
guaranteed that
either the system or the environment
will have a winning strategy and at this
point
the algorithm germinates
now obviously your hope is that one of
those strategies will be
found much much earlier than that
and indeed that's that's usually
uh the case but in principle
um you know that you will have
a solution
okay now i want to
quickly come back to other this question
um
before we maybe go into uh into the
more advanced uh challenging areas
and so so her question was um
do we get good solutions essentially
with all these methods
and the the answer is if you're not
careful
uh then uh no so
this is a small part of the um amba
case study just um
the part that uh that regulates uh
bursts of uh
transmission births of uh of length uh
four
and uh this was um computed by akatsiya
um so uh one of the early uh
tools and essentially you see that the
solution i mean there's no way to
understand what this
solution does i'm just showing you the
state space
uh without uh the actual inputs and
outputs uh but but still i mean
it's not it's very complex
now if you do bounded synthesis then
um you at least get a solution with a
minimal number of
states so this looks like this
which is i mean there's a much better
chance to understand this than the
previous solution but but it's
as it turns out uh also not yet
completely obvious
how this uh solution uh works
so what we actually do in the refinement
of this
algorithm is bonded cycle synthesis so
this minimizes the number of states
and additionally the number of cycles in
the
graph and suddenly it looks like this
and i mean you can now clearly see
how bursts of length 4
are tracked by the implementation so
putting in the these extra constraints
that choose among the many many possible
solutions a a good one
pays off so
representation is that all you have to
do is
put in these additional constraints that
enforce whatever property
you would like to have for your um
eventual solution and so
i mean the particular method i'm
describing here is bounded cycle
synthesis which minimizes the number of
simple uh cycles in the graph and
this turns out to be one of those really
useful parameters
so the reason is that the number of
cycles
in a finite state machine
is up to exponential in the
size of the finite state machine so
that means if you have a realizable ltl
formula
then your number of states is bounded by
two exponents
but the number of cycles may actually be
triple
exponential so if you put in constraints
that limit the number of states then you
box in the solutions
quite a bit but if you additionally box
in i mean limit the number of
cycles then you box it in exponentially
stronger than if you just had limited
the number of states
so you tighten the search space
uh much more and this seems to be
one of the reasons why why it's such a
good idea to limit
the number of cycles it focuses the
search
very much even more than just limiting
the number of
states and it leads to well-structured
solutions because you avoid
loops okay
so we have i guess about 30
minutes left um
i mean if if you want to ask questions
or make comments or so please
uh don't be shy um i would
i would like to ask a follow-up question
to my question if
that's okay so um good solutions minimal
solutions
um uh great but what if i wanted to
start to make the problem more
complicated
for example uh there are two senses in
which i can do this one i can have
extra constraints they may be syntactic
or not on what
my solution should look like the other
one
is i want to try to involve
the user into the loop and they want to
provide hints
in some sense about the structure of the
solution etc
so still i can come kind of imagine
having access to all solutions could be
helpful
because you can restrict and not having
access to all could be hurtful so
if i wanted to go beyond this is there
any hope for this these methods that are
optimal
because they don't represent all
solutions but can still accommodate
some of this
i mean you're now referring to quite a
big space of
potential algorithms so i mean i can
tell you for bounded synthesis the
answer is pretty clear you don't lose
any solutions
i mean what you're actually bounding
is the size of the certificate that
proves that you have a
correct solution so as long as
you pick a bound such that the solution
you're looking for has a certificate
within that bound
that then you're still fine now
depending on
what your criteria are on the solutions
that that may or may not be easily
compatible i mean if your solution is
such that it requires a huge certificate
then well you
better introduce a second parameter and
scale that differently and so forth
but but in principle that is certainly
uh possible
answering the same question or
these say low-level compositional
techniques you find in strict and
elsewhere is much more difficult
because of course your your low level
optimizations need to be compatible
with uh the search goal uh you have
and that's by no means a given upfront
right
so i i think um in the end to be
effective you want to have these low
level optimizations
but you you check better check whether
they're
compatible with whatever additional
constraints
you put on your problem
sorry that was a very handwritten answer
but i
um i don't think there's a general
answer to this question
maybe let me ask you back what kind of
constraints do you have in mind
i mean the simplest thing could be that
you know as as the
as the user i have some idea what the
shape
should be of uh the the kind of imagine
it's kind of like the
syntax of the state transition systems
that you
and i'm hoping this would actually make
things go faster
not i'm not trying to kind of be a
bother in some sense but help
and would it actually help if i
so think about it that in in three or so
months or terms i could
possibly kind of gen uh have have
defined israel's homophone that
represents all things of the same shape
and then i can intersect this with the
solutions and i can get
only solutions that look like this
but here you know this is just one
example but i i completely agree with
you that the question is a little too
broad it was just mostly to kind of no
no but
but it's a it's really an excellent
point uh so
i mean okay a variation of uh bounded
synthesis is for example
template-based synthesis where you don't
fix the
the number of states but rather you you
fix the state of the
the shape of the graph and so this has
been for example very successful in
building real-time controllers where you
do have a specific
um design pattern in mind
say the cyclic executive the circuit
executive steps
steps through a number of tasks in one
big cycle
right so you expect your solution to be
a cycle and the only thing that's open
is
in which order do you step through the
uh
through the different tasks and what
deadlines do you set right
so templates of this form
make a huge difference right first of
all they
they let you solve problems that would
otherwise be completely out of reach
because the search space
is too small and second of all you get
solutions that
make sense because they they uh they fit
a particular
um design pattern so
i i think actually this is one of the
um let's see the grand challenges i
think
um we don't have many such uh design
patterns or finite state machines
i mean it seems that the the more
abstract you become like if you go from
transition systems to real-time control
issues so
the more such things exist but of course
you would want to
like hard code such design patterns into
the
into the search such that at least you
prefer
to find a solution that follows a
pattern if if such a pattern exists
i have a question yes please
uh yes so so one of the biggest problems
in synthesis especially
of deep neural networks is
explainability i mean you have a
complicated problem with the synthesis
and and then
i think and you have no idea why it
works
so it is this is a general problem this
is i mean when i saw that
uh first diagram that was interesting
you had no chance to understand what's
going on there so what
do you think are the the key ingredients
that
are going to to push synthesis to make
it explainable you know such that it's
getting
acceptable you know from the point of
view of reactive synthesis
okay i have a beautiful slide for this
let me try to jump to that
um
yeah so so this is what uh dijkstra had
to say uh on this
though if we ever want to compose really
large programs
reliably we need a discipline such that
the intellectual effort
needed to understand the program does
not grow more rapidly than
proportional to the programmed length
so i mean he says like two times that
this is of course uh
all very loose uh but but i think that
that's a very uh interesting uh claim
because what classic
synthesis algorithms do is they work on
the
um on the product graph if you have
multiple components and then you analyze
the the program
just like verification would do in
principle right in order to make sure
that there is no bug
you look at the program the the product
um and that of course means that
even if we improve the synthesis
algorithms say
that they don't generate finite state
machines but they
they produce the corresponding code or
so
there's always this product construction
going on
that means that understanding that your
system is correct uh is actually
exponential in uh in the size of the
code sort of violating um dijkstra's
goal of having a linear
or let's say polynomial or so uh
dependency
and i mean of course the extras answer
uh to the
uh challenge was that you want to be
compositional so if
if you can look at one component at a
time and convince yourself that this
component
does the right thing because it
satisfies its specification
and because it additionally provides
whatever guarantees other components
might
might need from it then you can
understand components
locally rather than looking at the
product
so i think going towards compositional
methods is mandatory for two reasons
one because it's the only way to scale
up because you
you can't go to a non-elementary
complexity or even just exponential
complexity you want to be a
linear polynomial in the number of
components
but two also because compositionality is
our best way of making things
understandable
so if you minimize the interfaces
between the components then
you optimize the local i mean the
locality of the reasoning required
to understand the component and
if unavoidable then at least the
interfaces decouple
the reasoning from one component to the
other
in a way i think compositionality has
much more of a chance in
in synthesis than it ever had in
verification
because we get to pick the solution and
obviously there are solutions
that that are very local that that
work with a small interface between the
components and then there are other
solutions
that rely on a very intricate uh
collaboration and because we can't put
in additional constraints
we can force uh the synthesis to
to go towards uh the ones uh that are
local and understandable so yeah so this
is one of my favorites you're saying
that
you can do what you can do is to put as
a constraint for example architectural
constraints i mean
say look i think the system should have
this kind of architecture
maybe and so there you put some of the
composition
already exactly the system i mean
you don't have to be so strict as to say
you you make all solutions illegal
that rely on collaboration but of course
you could uh just bias the search
towards those solutions
that are more local and i think that's a
very good strategy all right
thank you very much how would you advise
this
search would you put additional
constraints or uh
i'm sorry i didn't fully understand when
you say bias to search
what are the standard tricks additional
constraints or giving
weights or
yeah i mean so in in bounded synthesis
it always boils down to
putting in a constraint that limits a
certain parameter
right so i think biasing the search
means
identifying the parameter and then
defining a preference between the
different parameters
as you scale up the search
simply because the the parameters are
usually of a type
that you know if you look for
the solutions for parameter n plus one
this is so much harder
than the solutions for parameter n such
that
you might as well forget everything you
did and start from scratch for the
higher parameter
but this may not be the case for all
types of parameters
in in other situations it may well be
worthwhile
to have an incremental solution style
so i i think you know this is completely
orthogonal but
the exciting question is what are the
right parameters you
all right
if there are no more burning questions
then i'll
maybe go back to my um
challenge slides but but please by all
means
interrupt it so it's probably much more
exciting if you make your comments
rather than me going for more slides
so i picked three
areas that i think are
um both fundamental and
and at a stage where um really something
uh something uh fundamental is going on
right
so i'm not sure if we have enough time
to go uh through them but
uh but let me get started uh with uh
reactive uh
programs so
all the techniques i mentioned in my
story so far
were concerned uh with the generation of
finite state machines or transition
systems and already
ten years ago madu sudan said that
this is actually completely wrong
because
in the end we don't want to build
transition systems
transition systems are infinite big uh
not understandable uh really what we
want
are programs and programs are
compact and and actually the artifact
we're really interested in
now you could of course argue well a
transition system is a special type of
program but i think the the criticism
runs
much or deeper than that so
let's say if you're um building a music
app and you want to use uh synthesis uh
for this fujita is smiling
because she knows where i'm headed uh so
this is actually work
by uh eddie stein and uh mark uh
santo luchito to really uh
outstanding uh researchers that fujitsa
and i were lucky enough
to uh supervise so i'll describe the
problem in a little bit of
their solution um so let's say you want
to synthesize a music app
so something like uh whenever you leave
the app
then uh the control should go and pause
and whenever you resume the app then it
should start playing
whatever track and track position uh it
was on when you left
the app so if you build a
code for an app like that there is
actually a lot
that you build on say there's the
android system the android music player
library the control interface
there is data like uh the the chosen
track
and so forth so it's not really
plausible
that you build the transition system
that
that governs all these things first of
all because you're building your
your system in an environment where a
lot of things are already
fixed and second of all it's not just
control
i mean there's a lot of data going on
like
the music and obviously you want to
refer to that even though
it's not really part of the control
problem
that you're solving
so in uh in this work
um the the key idea was to go
to the extension from ltl to
uh in this case a stream logic a
temporal stream
logic where the extension is that rather
than
just having atomic propositions you have
function terms and
predicates in your logic and you can
talk about
updates so you can say that the control
is updated with the result of the pause
function
right and you can say that without
knowing
what pause means it's just a function
provided by your system
so uh input variables refer to these
streams not necessarily boolean right we
have
all these functions and predicates and
uh
you specify when such updates need to
happen
referring again to the values of
predicates
so you can say that
if a certain predicate becomes true then
something needs to happen
without knowing exactly
what what that predicate means
so this allows you to do a functional
abstraction just like you know it from
programming right so your control
specification can refer
to functions and predicates that
somebody else may already have
programmed and then your your
synthesized solution fits in
that framework and just like if you were
a human programmer doing that
you don't necessarily know all the
details of
the functions that you're using but it
is your job
to call them correctly and this is what
you can do in
in such an extended
logic now the challenge is
that you're moving actually to a
different uh
logic because you have all these new
elements the functions and the
the predicates in there and this looks
very similar
to ltl but it's actually different
so in tsl you might say something like
if eventually the predicate p of x
becomes true
then you want it to eventually globally
stay true on on y
where x is an input and y is an output
variable
and this is not the same thing as saying
that there's a predicate p
x and a predicate p y and if eventually
i'm sorry an atomic proposition px and
an atomic proposition py
if eventually px becomes true then
eventually globally py
becomes true why is this not the same
well
the tsl specification is actually
realizable because this is a
predicate it's the same predicate p here
and there
so once i have found a value
x for which the predicate is true i can
just copy that value onto y
and then i have a value where this
predicate p will
will remain true forever right because y
is an output
and i can just pick that output for
example i can copy the value of x
in ltl where p x and p y
are not under my control there's always
an uh
an environment that will you know set p
x
to true at one point and uh p y
um forever uh to false
so the problem is different
and this is also reflected in the
decidability of the problem
so while um the ltl synthesis problem is
always
decidable the this more powerful
logic that has these uninterpreted
functions and predicates
has an undecidable synthesis problem
however this is clearly the synthesis
problem
you want to solve so what you do is
you approximate this problem that you
really want to solve
with one in ltl that's
as close as possible so in this case
we would take this property of the same
form and just correct for all the errors
that might result
from the approximation in in ltl
so the approximation that that
introduces the error is
that the predicate px and the predicate
py
can somehow be chosen independently of
each other this is
not the case here because they are the
same predicate just applied
to different terms so what we do is we
say that
okay we additionally put in
constraints that make the two logics
agree
so for example we say that if p is true
on x
and we assign x to y then in the next
step
p must be true for y or if p was true
for y
and we don't change the value of y then
in the next step
the predicate p of y must still be true
so in general you may need an infinite
number of such
additional constraints in order to
reflect
the behavior what we do in practice is
we simply correct for the error in a in
a
refinement loop that is we look for
serious uh
violations and uh and then one by one
correct these violations by adding
additional uh constraints
so the interesting observation is that
this works really well in in practice
you in practice you only need a few
iterations of this refinement loop in
order to eliminate uh the spurious
errors
then apparently you have a ltl
approximation that is
close enough uh to the tsl specification
so that you you find a solution uh that
works
and of course it's conservative in the
sense that if you find the solution then
that is an actual solution for the
original
problem but i think
logics like this could be a great
starting point to actually go
from finding transition systems to
finding programs that work
in in
existing architectures and uh that
are hierarchical in the sense that you
build one function at a time and uh and
then build more complex systems
once you have uh extended your framework
but of course there's a lot that that is
still missing from such a framework
so what what we did there was the
extension of ltl with
uninterpreted functions so that we can
handle
function calls that have already for
functions that have already been
implemented um but
we don't go beyond uninterpreted
functions so there's no reasoning going
on
that would actually talk about
the the theories that uh that occur
in the in the programs so i think uh if
you want
to build programs then the essential
question is
how do you combine the reasoning between
the the newly synthesized functionality
and the parts of the program that are
already there
i mean this could be a combination of
synthesis and
verification where in order to build a
good new program that uses some
functions you have to carry out some
analysis of the functions that are
already there
but it could also be a combination of
reactive synthesis and
deductive synthesis where once you have
figured out
how the control needs to be a deductive
synthesis approach can then build
the functions that you need in order to
have the correct
data transformations
all right
so
i think this is one of the big areas
going from
transition systems to actual
uh programs
ah we we don't have too much time i
think this is maybe
this goes also this goes also in
direction of understanding
understandability i mean obviously
you know because
these programs are such more higher
level that that it's much easier to
understand them
and they are structured
i think understandability is a big uh
part of the story
but it really goes beyond that i mean
the the classic version of church's
problem attempts to build the whole
system in one go
right you have one specification and you
build one solution that
satisfies the specification no matter
what but you don't build programs in
this way
you don't start from scratch but rather
you already have some parts and then you
build new parts that use what you have
already built
i mean partly that is due to uh
understanding what you're doing right
but partly it's also to manage
complexity you you don't want to um
to build a big system in one go so
that's a big disadvantage of of these
classic algorithms
anna please and you have a question
yes hi uh i have a question about
counter examples
so let's see but it's also related to
explainability
in a way so let's say that we want to
provide more exponentiality
by detecting more of these counter
examples from which we can
learn how to improve our system
is there any way how we can guide this
counter example search
so to say that that our method would
remember what counter examples we
already
found and how to find counter examples
that are close to what we've seen so far
or maybe
very different from what we've seen so
far
yeah very good question so i
think um partly the answer is uh that
the
search for counter examples really is uh
dual
to the i mean the dual version of the
problem to the search for
implementations
because if you have a specification
that's not realizable
then the environment has a strategy
to prove this right to make it
impossible for the system
to satisfy the specification
so given that we have a specification
that's unrealizable
you you want uh um
you want such a counterexample that
optimizes some parameter right maybe
it's the shortest way
to get to the error or it's the one that
uses the least
memory and so forth right so so again
it is a synthesis problem it's just that
this time we're not building the
implementation but rather the
um the counter strategy um
but in a way the the same um uh
the same rules uh apply
i hope that this is sort of what you
were aiming at i mean
there's of course the bigger issue how
do we uh how do we explain
what what went wrong in in the first
place
so for example
we can look for minimal sub
specifications that are already
unrealizable
and and all these uh techniques that
that help us understand
uh the problem but i
i think in the end it boils down to
finding the the counter strategy
and uh letting the user sort of try to
do
its best i mean his or her best against
that counter strategy
because you know that's what proves that
your problem is unrealizable
i can't see you so i am you have to
say whether you're happy or not yeah
yeah i'm
sort of happy yes i mean it explains of
course um
it makes a lot of sense that we if we
have a strategy how to find solutions we
should also figure out the counter
strategy how to find counter examples
that we're looking for um yeah i was
just also wondering if
if there is a way to automate this
process such that we
remember what we've found so far or
maybe
such that we have some kind of automatic
guidance but it would of course
also make sense if we have feedback from
the user and
this would guide us as well
i i think i mean the
the whole question what what should be
this i mean the
how should the cooperation work between
the synthesis algorithm
and the human user is one that's
tremendously uh
interesting because um
the the idea in in church's uh
problem that the the user writes a
specification and then is done
right then the algorithm takes it from
there
is obviously uh nonsense uh because uh
you you make so many errors in inviting
your specification
and uh it's it's not at all obvious that
you're done
just because the synthesis algorithm
produced
some solution because if if your
specification is
uh nonsense then why
why should the implementation be
anything other than uh
nonsense so i think
that that's one of the the reasons why
you don't want to see it as a
you know producer consumer kind of
relationship
but it is definitely one of uh of an
interaction
and uh i mean there are some ideas out
there
uh one is interactive synthesis where
you start with a small
uh specification and that is then
i mean that leads to a small
implementation that is hopefully small
enough
so that you can still understand what it
does and then you add a requirement
and then you get an explanation that
tells you why the the simple solution
that he had so far
is no longer good on the in light of
that additional
requirement and then you get a fix that
that
also adjusts i mean also accounts for
this additional requirement
and now your your implementation gets
more and more complicated because it
needs to accommodate more and more
uh requirements but at least you
understand and each
transformation step why that step
happened
and what it changed in the in the
program so maybe this is a way
to ensure that in the end you understand
what the synthesis
has produced but
i think uh i mean
this problem has so many facets that uh
um we haven't started to understand it
yeah thank you i think this is what you
mentioned so
uh right now this is addressed in the
advert paper isn't it
it's very good okay okay
the neville i will look definitely more
into this very interesting thank you
here comes actually we're i think we're
running out of time
then but your talk is really exciting
how do you do you have an estimate how
many more minutes you have or you have
actually enough slides for two more
hours
now you see i'm through the part
that covered the basic history and the
fundamental algorithms
and now i have slides left that
talk about some exciting directions
but i think it's perfectly fine if we
don't get to those
today i purposefully did not
you know rush ahead because i think
we'll have ample opportunity to talk
about these things at other
occasions so my suggestion would be
since
we are indeed out of time uh why don't
we just
finish up at this point i think
i mean the bottom line for me is that uh
synthesis has made this um amazing uh
journey from this theoretical problem
to something that at least holds the
promise to be really useful in
in practice and it it has a 60-year
history but it has tremendously taken up
speed
in the last uh say 15 years since the
umber protocol and all these
practical uh benchmarks so
i think it is a really exciting
uh problem still after 60 years
uh because it has so many um fundamental
assets where we simply know nothing at
this point
so i think it was a wonderful idea to
choose synthesis as the topic of this
program and then this uh seminar so
um let me close with this and uh yeah
i look forward to many more discussions
on this
okay so i guess then i will listen to
the as our speaker
and uh let's think uh finish now we are
only two minutes
uh after the time so thank you very much
ben for this fantastic
tutorial it was really great it was
exactly what we wanted to learn to bring
everyone up on the speed
and i guess you're right we have still
the whole semester ahead of us
so we will have chance to address this
topic so everyone
let's give a warm thank you to ben and
if you uh
see the person who knows him if you have
any questions or you would like to know
more
just being him he's really he will
gladly answer at least i assume you will
definitely thanks very much yes and ben
is also participant so you can probably
just ping him
at uh uh gather towns coffee places and
stuff so
thank you once again ben thank you and
let's go ahead
bye bye everyone thank you bye bye